good evening
everyone my name is johnine and I wanted
to welcome you to the table and everyone
online welcome we're so glad that you're
here with us this afternoon evening
afternoon whatever it is you know how it
goes um I have a couple of announcements
uh for you uh B AP ISM classes there
tonight and next Sunday right after the
service uh Brett will be offering a
baptism class uh for those that are
interested in learning more about this
uh ancient Sacrament and remember
attending this class doesn't
automatically commit you to be baptized
but if you are interested baptisms will
be on Sunday January the
14th this year we have a real treat
because Christmas Eve is a sun Sunday
and so our services here at the table
for Christmas Eve will be held at 400
p.m. that's earlier than normal so
everyone mark your calendars 4
p.m. all right so now
let's H just take a moment to prepare
ourselves for
worship Heart Of All Hearts soul of All
Souls
we watch and we wait for the joy that
you bring into this
world thank you
johnine you guys want to stand with us
we're GNA start off with a Christmas
carol as it is already December 10th
can't believe
it y'all sing along if you know it's Joy
to the
World I just remembered I'm starting
this
one one
[Music]
two Joy to the World the Lord is come
let Earth receive her
King let every heart prepare him ru
heaven and nature sing and heaven and
nature sing and heaven
heaven and nature
[Music]
sing Joy to the Earth the Savior Reigns
let all their songs
employ while Fe fields and floods rocks
Hills and Plaines repeat the sounding
Joy repeat the sounding Joy
[Music]
weeat the sounding
Joy
repeat the sounding Joy the sounding Joy
the sounding Joy
weeat the sounding Joy the sounding Joy
the sounding
[Music]
Joy
no
more and Sorrows grow no thorns in fense
the
grow he comes to make His blessings flow
far as the curse is found far as the
curse is found far as for as
the curse is
found her rolls her rolls the world with
truth and Grace and makes the nation
Pro the glories of his
righteousness and wonders of his love
and wonders of his love and wonders
[Music]
wonder and wonderers
wonder and wers
wonder his
love sing
repeat repeat the sounding Joy the
sounding Joy the sounding Joy
weeat the sounding Joy the sounding Joy
the sounding
[Music]
Joy the sounding Joy the sounding Joy
the sounding
[Music]
Jo all right kiddos y'all are
dismissed
thank you guys for joining
us and thank you kids ministry workers
for all that you're doing
tonight we hope it's a great
night may they be joyful and well
[Music]
behaved we're going to move into the
prayers of the people if you guys would
join me and read this prayer aloud with
us and then we'll pause for you guys to
speak out loud a name or situation
that's on your heart and then we'll wrap
up the prayer together
again Jesus for the city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and will to conserve it we pray
to
you for the old and the sick for for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you
[Music]
Jacob for the names and the moments that
we have SP spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence
[Music]
amen
sping out of control I feel it losing my
defenses no it's not easy letting go and
trusting
[Music]
you and if
I'm Hest I know that though you've said
you you got it no it's not easy letting
go and trusting
you so I'll stop so I will stop Brea
rest here in your goodness I know you
won't leave it's my confidence it's my
confidence I will stop breathe rest here
in your goodness I know you won't leave
it's my confidence it's my
[Music]
confidence spending out of control I
feel it losing my defense says no it's
not easy let go and
trusting
[Music]
you be onest I know that though you say
you got it no it's not easy let go when
trusting
you I will St Brea bre rest here in your
goodness I know you only it's my
confidence it's my confidence I will
stop rest here in your goodness I know
you only it's my confidence it's my
confidence here I am in the pal of your
head nothing can take me away nothing
can take me away here I am in the palm
of your head nothing can take me away
nothing can take me
[Music]
away not a or a death not a lie inside
my head not a fear or offense nothing
can take me
away not aight or a not a lie inside my
head not a fear or offense nothing can
take me
away not a height or a death not a lie
inside my head not a fear or offense
nothing can take me
away not a hide over death not a lie
inside my head not a fear
nothing can take me
away nothing can take me away nothing
can take me away nothing can take me
away nothing can take me
away here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me
away here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away it's my confidence it's my
confidence it's my confidence it's my
confidence it's my
confidence it's my confidence confence
it's my confidence
it's my confidence confidence it's my
[Music]
confidence I wanted to read to us
tonight in Psalm 120 it
says woe to me
that I dwell in
mesek and when I was reading it today I
heard woe to me that I dwell in this
land that I live among these
people too long have I lived among those
who hate
peace I lift my eyes up to the mountains
where does my help come
from my help comes from the Lord the
maker of heaven and of
Earth
[Music]
God I look to
you I won't be
[Music]
overwhelmed give me
Vision to see things
like you do God I look to you you're
where my help comes
from give me
[Music]
wisdom you know just what to
do
[Music]
yeah
God I look to
you I won't be
over give me
Vision to see things like you do God I
look to
you you where my help comes
from give me
wisdom you know just what to do
[Music]
will love you Lord my
Str and I will love you Lord my
[Music]
sh I will love you Lord my
love forever all my days I will love you
God
hallelujah our
[Music]
god
hallelu
God hallelujah
[Music]
God forever all my days
huj he will not let your foot
slip He Who Watches Over you will not
Slumber or
sleep the Lord Watches Over You and he
is your shade at your right hand the sun
won't harm you by day nor the Moon by
Night the Lord will keep you from all
harm he will watch over your life the
Lord will watch over you in your coming
and in your going both now and forever
more Hallelujah
[Music]
God
hallelu our
[Music]
god
hallelu god reigns forever all my days
hallelujah
hallelujah our god
[Music]
hallelu
God
God forever all my days
hallelujah forever all my days
hallelujah
[Music]
h
God what a gift to
know your Divine
love that watches over our coming and
our
going that protects
us that sees us through the
storms and the
stress that bandages our
wounds that heals our
hurts that sits with us in our
grief and rejoices with us in our
[Music]
victories God where we have only known
you as someone distant or something far
off this season in this Christmas time
God as we think about how you came to
Earth how you made yourself
flesh God would you feel closer than our
own breath closer than the blood in our
veins would you be the heartbeat that
guides us that settles us that grounds
us into our home into who you created us
to
be would we live into the identity of
who you created us
as a people who are loved who are
seen thank you Jesus Emmanuel God who is
with
us we love
you continue to show us your way and
guide us in your path in Jesus name
amen you guys can turn to the people
around around you make them feel
welcomed
please
well Grace and peace it is so good to be
with you all my name is uh Brett and man
it's a it's a joy it's always a joy to
like be here but uh especially this time
of year it is um yeah there's something
about being together and uh and singing
a Carol it's been a while so it's yeah
it's beautiful um and it is it's a joy
to be with you all but I also want to
mention um especially those joining us
online yall have not forgotten um love
you lots and um anyone here who is new
thank you for for being with us and
Among Us um yeah I know it can take a
lot of courage to come through those
doors just kind of kind of kind of a lot
and so U just know we are really really
glad that you're that you're here so um
we are in week two in our Advent series
and uh for those kind of unfamiliar with
this season in the in the church
calendar um the the word Advent comes
from the Latin um which is adventus and
uh that means arrival so in essence um
Advent is not exactly the same as like
celebrating Christmas per se um you know
the arrival of Christ but it's um it's
right it's the um the season of
preparation for his arrival it's um that
that time of kind of reflection as we
prepare our own hearts and Minds to
receive Christ into the world um so with
that in mind
um the the title of my message today
it's a unique one it is
repent exclamation mark all caps
everything they're like he's going all
fundamentalist on us like um you'll kind
of see where I'm going for those who are
like what we're in church this is normal
um well I guess you you'll see as we as
we get into it I don't usually preach on
you know sermons like this um so last
week we kind of were reimagining the
word um saved uh and and kind of uh
rehabilitating that in our own minds um
and so this week it'll be the word repin
so um we get this there's two kind of
lectionary readings that I want to cover
um one from is from the prophet Isaiah
the next one is from the gospel of Mark
um so we'll start with this first
reading from Isaiah says Comfort Comfort
my people says your God speak tenderly
to Jerusalem and Proclaim to her that
her hard service has been completed that
her sin has been paid for verse three a
voice of one calling in the wilderness
prepare the way for the Lord make
straight in the desert a highway for our
God every Valley shall be raised up
every mountain and Hill made low the
rough ground shall become level the
rugged places a plain and the glory of
the Lord will be revealed and all people
will see it together for the mouth of
the Lord has spoken can I get an amen
that's some that's some poetry right
there that's powerful
uh so who is this this voice of one
calling in in the wilderness prepare the
way for the lord well the gospel of Mark
uh gives us that that answer and uh so
that's the the second reading here Mark
1-5 the beginning of the good news about
Jesus the Messiah the Son of God as it
is written in Isaiah the prophet I will
send my messenger ahead of you who will
prepare your way a voice of one calling
in the wilderness prepare the way for
the Lord make straight paths for him and
so John the Baptist appeared in the
wilderness which is there's your answer
that's who this one is right who will
prepare the way for Christ so John the
Baptist appeared in the wilderness
preaching a baptism
of
repentance for the Forgiveness of
sins so John the Baptist he he often
figures quite prominently in Advent kind
of readings because he is like the the
perfect Advent figure right he is not
himself Christ
but he is the one who comes before
Christ to announce right the the the
arrival and so he's just you know just
perfect um for it and um you know this
season as I mentioned earlier Advent
isn't exactly the celebration of
Christmas but the the the preparation
and so you know what does that look like
well it's it's um part of it is this
word repentance that that John kind of
names here is why people coming out to
be baptized um by him was this this word
repentance and obviously that's not I
would say that's not a word we use much
uh at least outside the church probably
the only place you'll ever hear is in
church you know it's not like I don't
know you're just at work and someone's
like repent you know it's just like it's
a weird weird thing to say we don't say
that um so you know it's only in church
and even here um as I kind of alluded to
uh it's it well it's kind of interesting
I think a lot of churches sort of shy
away from it completely right and are
just sort of like it is a damaged word
and we're just not touching it you know
so there's kind of that group and then
there's those who really like it they're
like really into it every sermon could
just be repent exclamation mark you know
um so there's kind of these two camps
you know never the two it's like a VIN
diagram with just they never meet you
know it's just kind of um so I want them
to meet and uh and I I want us to kind
of rethink reimagine um this word based
on scripture then not just like our own
I don't know uh sensibility or something
like well it's offensive so let's change
it you know like no no based on
scripture I want us to re rethink what
it means because I think honestly where
it's kind of gone in a lot of people's
minds I I think you know in church when
we say repent you know I think where our
minds go is something
like uh feel very very sorry for your
sins you know it's like hey do you feel
bad about your sins you don't feel bad
enough you know repent AKA ramp up ramp
it up ramp up those guilty feelings and
that's what it means you know we're all
going to have a time of a season of
repentance AKA we're all going to feel
real bad you know and that's kind of
what that's is what repentance means in
our minds um but I I don't I I think
that is it's missing the point it's
almost like we've so
emphasized certain feelings that often
um Can accompany repentance um you know
and kind of good and bad like there's I
don't know we've all right at times done
things that we have in essence repented
for we've said that was wrong you know
I'm so sorry and felt feelings around
that you know it can be some guilt um
and maybe at the very least regret you
know and so I think what we've kind of
done though is started in church spaces
at least that especially use this word a
lot is kind of emphasize that so it's
like we're trying to get people to that
place even through kind of emotional
psychological manipulation you know so
it's something powerful about a
microphone and maybe I should come back
up here for this you know that's better
like higher up you know there's those
Dynamics kind of um play a role we start
trying to Drum It Up in people um and I
think the way I'd maybe put it is while
um feelings can be a part of repentance
for sure um we might even say it's like
feelings on the train cold repentance
feelings are often you know a uh a a cab
you know in that they're one of the the
trucks a part of the train um but there
it's it's not the
engine not the engine of the train so
which kind of gets me thinking like so
what is you know what's the engine
what's the like heart of of this word um
and so let's let me go back into the
original Greek so the the Greek word
here that's translated in most English
Bibles as repentance is the word
metanoia means change of mind or really
more accurately would be change of heart
uh heart's it's the better word but it's
again often shy away from because of the
connection to feelings so when people
hear heart oh I need a change of heart
and we connect our heart with you know
the feeling ins side of us like oh my
heart's so broken you know it's like Ah
that's what it's about feelings when
actually uh we alluded to this I alluded
this like I don't know probably three or
four weeks ago in a message um it's
maybe better to think of when we hear
even Jesus talk about the heart to think
think more of like the deepest places
from which we think and live uh the soul
um even I called it um following
Theologian Maggie Ross's um Deep
Mind and like that actually I think this
is what repentance is about is a shift
there so in other words um it's it's a
shift in the deepest places from which
we think and live
and
um this I think starts to change it
starts to shift things because suddenly
um you know what repentance is about we
might even say it's an aha kind of
moment you ever had that like that that
kind of moment where you know like
oh everything must change now like
things must be different from this point
on I I see it and I see it clearly right
that like that's the thing right that's
a deeply human thing that's that's um
and by that I mean and also at the same
time deeply and profoundly spiritual I
mean we've all had those moments which
is why I think it's sort of a shame when
repentance repent you know becomes so
religious and kind of hokey and
connected like feel super bad it's like
we we miss the whole resonance of the
word which is just in an aha a Moment of
clarity a moment of really seen and and
of course you know we kind of in ways
like the way that plays out in our life
it's different right for each and every
one of us you almost have to um kind of
fill in the blank like for some of us
it's it's that um that kind of aha
moment
around the
envy that like you look back on your
life life and you realize oh my God this
has been like a major theme for me I
have got to let this
go and you like in that moment like you
see it right or maybe um maybe it's that
rage that rage it is that goes so deep
within you and you keep it kind of Under
Wraps here you know Church whatever but
it jumps out and but suddenly you have a
moment where like you see it and you
know oh my gosh this has been running my
life in all the wrong
ways uh maybe it's it's um maybe it's
even just a desire like this kind of
propensity towards a desire for Oblivion
that often can manifest in like um
substance abuse kind of issues you know
but not just there it can even be kind
of virtual like kind of just
disappearing into Virtual Worlds and and
and um so to speak you know I mean just
kind of like so much television or what
you know whatever it's just like I am
checking out here I'm just Peace Out
World you know as much you work and you
peace out you know and but suddenly you
see
it like you see it and you
know like
crap I I can't do that anymore like what
is that that that's it that's what the
Bible calls metanoia it's it's
repentance it's it's an aha moment in um
in the 12-step World um I think they
would call this hitting rock
bottom you know and here's the thing
it's not just right about kind of
classic addiction or something like this
is for all of us we've we've all like
hit rock bottom and some right because
we've all had this kind of moment and
the thing what I love about the 12-step
Insight is um they point out that it's
you know no one can have that on your
behalf you know like it can't be when
your grandma sees it clearly and she
knows sweetheart you need a change you
know I mean like no it can't be your
grandma or your spouse or your best
friend or like you really need you know
like I mean they can prod or encourage
or exhort you to but ultimately who has
to see
it I got to see it for me you have to
see it for you
right like we we know this to be true
and that's that's um that's that's what
metanoia that's what repentance is all
about it's where um not my grandma but
when I see it clearly when you might
even say when God speaks to me about it
which for some of us can be quite real
for some of you really hear from God in
like very tangible ways you're like whoa
you know and for others it's more subtle
but you
know you know when it's happening right
um and so I think each of us you know
each of us must face this in ourselves
um you might even say each of us must
see not just it as though it's something
outside of us like that's a real problem
you know no we must um somehow see it in
us we must um realize the ways in which
kind of our lack of repentance or our
struggle in these areas has kind of
caused us to leave
ourselves is that resonate with anyone
kind of to it's like I've been gone from
home for so
long here you know what I mean here like
just been
gone um in Repentance what it's that
moment we come
home we come
home home to ourselves there's a a
famous story uh Jesus tells in in Luke
15 um it's probably I think it's one of
the most moving um stories that that
Jesus tells it's the it's one of um the
two
sons often known as the prodical son but
really it's about two sons and uh so
there's the father has these two sons
and the they both have their issues
we'll put it that way um the younger or
the older son hyper responsible never a
day off go go go trying desperately to
earn his father's approval you know so
um he's got kind of his own issues but
the younger son is kind of what the
story center is around and he the
younger son if you're familiar with the
story he definitely had his issues so he
goes to his father and he basically says
uh I want my inheritance now which
theologians kind of look into like the
nuances of that in the culture and was
that normal back then my hunch is I
don't think it's normal really in any
culture ever when your parents are alive
be like hey uh can you pay up now you
know it's a weird we don't do that um
you know so but he does this I want my
inheritance now without so much as a
word of protest his father uh just gives
it to
him and uh the Bible says that within a
few days the younger son um he took all
that he now owned and he journeyed into
the far
country you ever been there in the far
country
we all
have even the even the best Among Us so
to speak you know whatever that kind
of um that's what's the weird thing
about the story if you read it closely
even the older son is in the far country
in his own way his own heart and mind
you know um but the younger son was more
obvious he literally goes he leaves goes
to the far country and the text says um
and there he squandered everything he
had in Reckless living it kind of keeps
it vague you know let your imagination
fill in the details uh in Reckless
living and uh when it rains it pours
though right so suddenly there is a a
famine that strikes the land and this
younger son goes from being someone who
is like presumably the richest guy in
town to
overnight like CU When the running mons
out run or when the money runs out it's
just out right it's just gone and so
suddenly is like the poorest he gets so
poor he hires himself out to a farmer
and his job keep in mind he's um Jesus
was Jewish he's speaking to a primarily
Jewish audience if you remember his job
to feed who or what the pigs uh you can
imagine for right the way that resonates
with the Jewish audience like it is
right back to um we were talking earlier
about Rock
Bottom there you go you know so there he
is but the Bible um
um even says it says that he was he was
so hungry that he was longing to eat the
food that the pigs were
eating and then there's this turn of
phrase the more literal translations I
think put it beautifully um I have a few
this is verse 17 this is the English
Standard Version um says but when he
came to himself or the Dewey RS Bible
and returning to himself or the literal
Standard Version and having come to
himself like what what was that moment
like that's the metanoia
moment that's the repentance
moment right can you see where um we
start
to um we miss it when we just think it's
all about feeling bad like no no no like
that's the moment when he came to
himself it was like in that moment
suddenly he saw it not his dad not his
older brother not his grandma like no it
was when he saw it when he came to
himself it's a startling awareness the
fruit of coming back to ourselves and
unsurprisingly it's that same moment
that he decides to return home to return
to his father like that's the can you
see
the yes there's pain here yes I'm sure
he had all sorts of feelings probably
some guilt you know but that's not the
main thing it wasn't like God was trying
to hope you feel bad you know so you
change your life like no God's so loving
and patient towards us God just Waits
just Waits while we're out there in the
far country doing our thing and waits
until we see it until we see it and
then it's the metanoia moment it's the
repentance moment the aha moment uh one
of the great performance of our
performance artists of our time is
Marina Abramovich she like kind of
toiled in somewhat of obscurity I guess
most performance artists do I don't know
how many performance artists can you
name you know it's like I don't know uh
so she was kind of known well in the
Avant guard kind of art world but um in
2010 you might recognize her or know her
because she like hit it she like went
mainstream um with her piece it was the
uh the Modern Museum of Art there in New
York City and the piece right for a
performance artist for those UNF
familiar is um it's not she doesn't
paint or saying or something instead
it's like she is the art things she does
um um with herself with her presence
with her body like this is the art and
you can go research her like she is an
incredibly courageous like some of the
stuff she has done Inc I mean
mindblowing like uh just incredibly
vulnerable just powerful but 2010 she
kind of breaks through mainstream with
this piece and it was called the artist
is present it was very simple um she
went uh there she got a room there in
the Modern Museum of Art and she sat
down at at a table for 7 and 1 half
hours every day for 3 months and across
from her there's a chair and anyone that
wanted could come and sit across from
her for as long as they
wanted so when she was planning this the
people kind of you know in her uh kind
of circle and herself they kind of
planned like no there's probably going
to be you know a lot of time sitting
across from no one I mean this is you
know like what kind of an art piece is
this you just come and sit across from
the AR you know um but they could not
have been more wrong it was a sensation
she never had one second where someone
wasn't sitting across from her people
lined up out like the the line snaked
all the way outside of the museum like
down there and wherever it is in New
York down the street like people people
camped out
overnight to hold their place in line to
to be there um and now who I'm of course
I know people had all sorts of reasons
for doing this you I'm sure some just
like want to say I was there for this
famous piece you know especially once
the New York Times or whatever did a
piece on and then people you know come
I'm I'm sure um who I'm most intrigued
by though are those who in the process
of sitting across from her got
incredibly
emotional um like this was extremely
moving for people and she didn't say
anything she just sat there and she
would just
look and it like broke people's
hearts there's I mean I'm sure you could
write a book about all of the reasons
why and like what's going on in a
culture where people like just sitting
like this makes them cry I mean there's
right there's depths to that but kind of
reflecting on these folks um Abramovich
she she put it this way she said what is
happening here here I am looking at you
you are photographed you're filmed you
are observed by everyone else in this
room so there's nowhere to go but into
yourself at the moment when you really
get into
yourself that moment you burst with
emotions with so many feelings this is
why so many people start crying and it
becomes such an important experience in
their
life right what she's OBS kind of naming
here or emphasizing is the power I think
of the
Gaze the power of really being
seen but my question is like why the
tears I I think probably for each person
it's completely different it's
interesting that in those faces um
sometimes
it's well for many of them there I would
say it's not so much joy there's like a
certain grief or relief can you kind of
see that
like there's there's what's going I I
think this I don't know maybe for some
of them it was a metanoia kind of moment
a a repentance kind of moment regardless
of their exact reasons for crying I
think this is such a powerful
picture of the repentance
encounter I think repentance is like
it's like per performance art with God
it's like God is there we had a quote
last week um from Rowan Williams about
how um God Waits patiently in our here
while I'm there I'm like anywhere but
here I'm there you know and that's I
think it's like repentance is that
moment with God where the Lord is so
good and so loving and just Waits
patiently just like that father in the
prodical son story Waits patiently for
us to reach
turn and in that moment when we come
back to
ourselves something in US
shifts something in US changes this is
why um tears are often not always but
often a sign that this kind of moment is
happening like just reflect back on your
life in
those uh moments right aren't tears
often like
they're there they're present
right I I
think that's what's happening between us
in God um the way Father Richard Roar
put it he said the real meaning of
repentance is seeing what you've chosen
not to
see as usual Richard Roar can put in one
line what my entire sermon is trying to
say you know he has that gift I think
that's beautifully put it's that's what
it is right can you see where we miss it
when it's like oh it's about feeling B
feeling so guilty I hope I really feel
you know like no it's like that's
completely maybe we'll feel something
and when we see what we've chosen not to
see right perhaps but that's like that's
the thing that's the that's the moment
is the return and the
scene uh and so I I think kind of
reflecting on these tears the tears of
the folks in the artist is present the
tears of The Prodigal Son
the tears of those who came to John to
be baptized I'll just sum it up like
this I think repentance is both pain and
joy it's the pain it is painful to
experience what is false being torn away
to see in myself what I would rather not
and in this way to come back to
myself however in that metanoia
repentance moment I am also planting the
seeds of Joy I'm planting the seeds of
Joy but why because like how can there
be Joy if you're not there like if
you're not living in reality if you're
off in the far country there's no joy
out there I mean there's like moments
there's Thrills you know you like get
high you know or something like I'm
thrilled you know it's amazing had a
success there's Thrills but not like not
Joy not Joy but oh when we return home
when we return to ourselves to God oh
it's Joy it's Oho very good so um kind
of in closing I have just two more quick
thoughts first can you see that
repentance is not a one-time thing can
you see that like we kind of get off
when it's sort of like even trying to
boil it all down to like one moment like
some of you tonight need to repent you
know so come down there aisle and you
know and as and and there can be I think
something good in that like you know but
we miss it I think when we try to get it
into like oh okay I get it I get it
Brett like yes so I need to have a
metanoid a repentance moment and then
I'll be healed you know and it's like
okay actually it's can you see that it's
a whole lifestyle it's like a whole way
of kind of catching ourselves in the far
country like when we're like running
away you know and then it's this
constant return so that's the first
thing um um second thing can you see
that advent is a refining Fire And what
I mean by that is it's it's not just oh
look at sweet baby Jesus in the manger
isn't he so cute like Talladega Nights
Ricky Bobby style you know just oh
that's sweet Jesus I just love Christmas
you know uh like can you see like no no
no this is John the Baptist of this is a
refining fire it it is um it is the
flame of love and it but it's but it's
good because it is planting the seeds of
future Joy it's planting the seeds of
future joy in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit amen amen so as
we uh as we come to the table of the
Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine
my my prayer my hope is that it would be
a a moment of return for you a moment of
repentance again not in some weird guilt
trippy way but in a in a
lifegiving aha kind of moment like God
loves me God sees me God accepts me
right where I am you know maybe you've
been out this week maybe it's just been
a beating for you and you need a moment
of return I I pray that this would um
would be that that moment for you so the
way we'll um do this tonight is we'll
just uh in a moment I'll invite you to
the table and we'll just go row by row
uh and so when one one row finishes the
next one can go ahead and come up um we
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then regardless of
your exact you know theology or
denominational background or whatever um
you're you're welcome to to participate
um you should know the red is wine the
white is grape juice and uh then finally
you can just partake whenever you'd like
no one will walk you through the exact
moment some people take it right away
some like to return to their seats and
kind of in a a posture of quiet um take
it then so this is the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
[Music]
table
for
[Music]
I'm really thankful for Brett's message
tonight it's been um I kind of get a
sneak peek sometimes on what his message
is going to be because we're planning
out the services together and uh I've
been thinking through that phrase of uh
like coming back to himself returning to
himself um ever since Wednesday whenever
he shared it with me and it's been so
helpful um because for me when when I
think about
uh my repentance Journey it's usually
beat myself up for a really really long
time for how bad I
am and you know then figure it out and
get it right and I loved that in this
story and the way that Brett was telling
it um the far off country was not the
true self the far off country is
something that was pulling you away from
who God really created you to be from
what he sees in us you know what I mean
so instead of you get it wrong and you
you know feel asham feel really bad it
was like that's not who you are come
back
come back home because who you are is
good who you are is like a child made in
the image of God and that's what he sees
and that what you know who he wants us
to be and uh it's just been so helpful
for me so we're closing with a song
called um May you find a light and um I
just felt like it was such a beautiful
picture of just this journey that we go
on when sometimes we are traveling far
from ourselves traveling to the far
country like Brett talked about and just
hoping that we can find that light that
brings us back home brings us back to
God back to Center um so you guys are
welcome to sit back and just enjoy this
um Jesse's voice and his guitar today as
we were practicing was just truly like
ministering to me like that's the only
word I could actually I was like I can't
believe I'm using this word it's
ministering to me I don't know another
word like it's healing places in me
right now so if you want to just sit
back and enjoy that and let it speak to
you let it heal you um you are welcome
to or if you feel like joining in as you
catch on to the chorus if you want to
sing along this is this is whatever you
need it to be so go ahead and lead us
[Music]
Jesse
lost
and weary
Traver searching for
the way to to
go
stranger heavy
hearted longing for
some one you
know may you
find a
light may you find a
[Music]
light may you find
Delight to guide you
[Music]
home there
are we
Travers searching
every where you
[Music]
go
strangers who are
searching longing
deeply to be
known may you find a
[Music]
light may you
find a
[Music]
light may you find Del light to guide
you
[Music]
home
star of
wonder star of
light star with
royal
beut
bright with word
leading still
proceeding guide us to
thy
[Music]
may you
find a
[Music]
light may you
find a
[Music]
light may you find the light to guide
you home
[Music]
wow that was really amazing thank you
worship
team and thank you Brett for a beautiful
message and thank all of you for coming
tonight um we're so glad to see you um
um if you're new we would really love
for you to fill out a little card on the
table or um if you I don't know if
they've got the yeah QR codes up there
on the screen and you can fill out all
that information
online uh so that we can just follow up
with you answer a few questions that you
have and uh say thank you for you coming
to visit with us tonight uh again my
name is johnine and if you're in need of
a hug or prayer or just any kind of
General support you can come find me
after the service and I'll be happy to
uh uh to meet with you here at the table
we're committed to creating an inclusive
Christ centered community that touches
lives and generosity is a key component
of that mission and if you'd like to
join us in that opportunity and support
us financially then again you can go to
that QR code you can drop a donation in
the tiny little box on the table in the
hallway um or you can go to the website
theable tx.org
um also uh remember that there's a
baptism class immediately after the
service today and also you can uh do
that uh next week if you're interested
so stick
around
and now if uh you'd like to stand or um
you can stay seated but I would uh love
to send you out into your week uh with
this
blessing you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst
day so as you go go into your week ahead
with all of its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed have a good week and we'll see
you here again next Sunday thank
you may you
find a
light may you
find
alive
may you find a light to guide you
home may you find a light to guide
you